Norman Mailer author of Oswald's tale an
American mystery did you ever know Jack
Kennedy oh yeah not well but I met him a
few times and in fact I was covering him
on having him in before the 1960
election for Esquire and I've covered
the convention and then someone got me
an interview with him at Hyannis Port so
it was funny because I came in with two
two prepared pieces I was gonna throw at
him and I did and one of them was that
the Village Voice that had a they'd had
a poll on would you vote who'd you vote
for and one fellow had said well as
between Kennedy and Nixon Kennedy is a
zero and Nixon's a - solvent for Kennedy
and the other I forget it was May I
think well I don't remember us I won't
say when in for something on the order
of the Democrats were running an ad that
showed Richard Nixon with a very heavy
beard and they said underneath it would
you buy use would you trust this man
would you buy a used car from this man
and then went on to say however if you
bought the car from Jack Kennedy you
would trust him
and you would buy the car and then after
you bought the car he'd drop by to visit
to see how it was working and each
seduced your wife so Kennedy without to
be shocked by that one because after all
this was 1960 you didn't approach
presidents that way and so he said well
the first ones kind of kind of absurd
you know I mean after all definitely was
zero and a - I mean I just really don't
think of myself as a zero and sure
Richard Nixon doesn't think himself as a
- and a little he said in the second one
well I really don't know what that means
and well he it was one of the few times
in everything around all I think it was
sort of cheeky what I was doing I fell
and as we were going outside he did
something looking back and I was so
clever because I'd thrown him he said
who was this guy what is he up to and he
made another mistake he said what kind
of car do you drive he said no let me
get let me guess it's a folks wagon
right I said no it's a triumph tr3 so
I had them twice I thought and the last
thing he said is come back tomorrow
we'll do another interview and bring
anyone you want so I made the mistake of
inviting my wife and the moment I did he
knew more about me than I knew about him
which is this poor fellow who's got to
bring his wife along to impress her
whereas if I'd brought off the
Schlesinger except what of that ilk he
would have known that he was dealing
with a fallible character so the second
interview was all his he controlled it
he was very skillful and charming yeah
he was perfect but those are the two
times I've met him but I didn't know a
lot of people who knew him so I kept
hearing stories about him and like all
presidents who know you very slightly
they make a political point of passing
messages on like like your last piece
very much but stuff of that sort you
would have been younger than him well
yes I was about three four years younger
I'm 72 now we have to reconstruct it
that was 35 years ago so I was 37 what
did you think he was 41 did you vote for
him oh yeah oh yeah no no he I was very
impressed with him he had a he had for
one thing I realized that he was a man
of many faces because I saw him over
these two days and I saw at least four
or five faces on him by the way that's
not uncommon for politicians I once
covered Maggie Thatcher and she had
three or four faces they were all
remarkable she could look like Queen
Elizabeth of the 16th century at one
moment and she could look like if she
was the passing through a mill with a
lot of British housewives doing mill
work she would tie a scarf around her
head and look like one of them if she
spoke to some Edinburgh Gentry she
looked like a woman of that country just
off her horse she she really had a lot
of faces and he had the same quality
Kennedy he at one point he he looked
like a professor he was comfortable he
looked like a man of forty-five even of
50 he was grey at the edges he had a
gentle intellectual face ten minutes
later he can look like a movie star
under the Sun speaking into to a
press-conference his face kept changing
he could
like an older brother kind of riding you
jiving you the moment we were outside
looking at the car was kind of
remarkable to me because he was saying
what kind of car you drive look I bet I
can guess and it was he was kind of like
a big guy kidding a little guy so he had
these sides and the day he was shot you
know I've been asked like it's funny
it's the one question I'm gonna ask
three or four times on this tour or I
guess it's natural it's an organic
question but it's an embarrassing
question for me because it's one of my
my least what I said my least
commendatory moments I was in a
restaurant with nan padorin so used to
be a great friend of the old days on the
lower of the middle east side of East
50s in Manhattan and was someone else
there I forget who and Jack Thompson was
his name that's it and there was the
news came in and I was very cynical I
was bitter at Kennedy at that point for
whatever reason and I said oh you know
that that shot just singed his scalp
he's not really hurt
he just letting us all wait for an hour
to so we realized we loved him and eat
him but in fact there's nothing going on
and of course an hour later he was dead
and I realized that I had a great you
haven't learned a great many things you
know you learned that over and over and
over again but that day I learned it
dramatically you haven't any memory at
all why you were mad at him at that time
well again I have to reconstruct it
who knows was some little thing probably
because after all the Bay of Pigs was
two years before that it could have been
for variety of reasons including petty
reasons maybe it was because he'd never
invited me to the White House I don't
pretend to be any better than the next
fella this book Norman Mailer's Oswald's
tale an American mystery if somebody
buys this what do they get in here well
you know I'd like to give a lot of value
for the dollars they're going to get a
good bit but if you ask me to sell my
own book alright I'll try to do that
they're gonna get a first of all they're
gonna get a an informal biography of Lee
Harvey Oswald which starts in the middle
the first half is about him at the age
of 19 billion to Russia and leaving
Russia at the age of 20
that's the first half of the book and
it's got a lot of new material about
Oswald Ian Rush and living in Minsk
getting married having children they're
trying to get along the Soviet system
becoming disillusioned and a lot of
detail on how he got out because he used
his wits he was very resourceful in
getting out of the Soviet Union he had a
fight the Russian bureaucracy and the
American State Department bureaucracy
and he finally ended up making so
uncomfortable and so unpleasant for each
bureaucracy that each one said let's get
rid of this problem they finally the
only way to solve certain impasses with
a bureaucracy is that you become so
intolerable the people in their office
say isn't there some way we can pass
this vintage estable morsel through our
system
and he succeeded in doing that in both
places people always felt very
mysterious that he got out and came back
but in fact it wasn't he just wore out
two bureaucracies all right then he came
back to the United States and the second
half of the book is all about Oswal in
America starting with him as a child and
carrying him through to the day of the
assassination and eat it what's the book
became as I wrote it was a was a
portrait of the Cold War as seen by
somebody who's living at the bottom in
both countries and the Cold War then
becomes a tragic comedy because there
was no war necessary not even a cold war
necessary in that the Russians that you
meet in this book are about like
Americans they're different in very
specific ways but they're very much the
same and maybe a little warmer because
one thing that does characterize
Russians I think because their history
has been so god-awful is that possibly
the first virtue for Russians is
compassion because everything in the
schema life and in Russian life over the
last century has been to one catastrophe
after another tends to tighten people up
tends to chill them tends to close them
down so that they become impervious to
feeling itself a Russian someone who can
respond sympathetically to your troubles
is a person of inestimable value and
over and over and over again what you
find when people are talking about
Oswald he would say I pitied him he was
so lonely he was here without a family
and you know the what came through also
was the extraordinary Russian sense of
family
very powerful I go back to the the first
time this book was even a possibility
for you who started it this book started
with Lawrence Schiller as the execution
of song did you know the book I wrote
about Gary Gilmore Schiller Lawrence
Schiller Larry had worked in in the
Soviet Union from off-and-on from about
1983 on because he was directing Peter
the Great the movie Peter the Great that
was put on in television and a
miniseries with Maximilian Schell a
couple years later and so he had
contacts in the Soviet Union and he
learned how to work with the bureaucracy
there and a given moment Soviet Union
started to fall apart and everything
began to open up and it looked like some
of the KGB files were going to indeed
open up he called me one day and said
listen would you be interested in doing
a book about Oswald and Russia because I
think I'm gonna have access to the
Oswald file so it came at a perfect time
for me I'd finished harlots ghosts which
some people may remember that at the end
of page 1300 I'd said to be continued so
the second half had to do with the
narrative being in Russian and I was
wondering how am I going to really deal
with the KGB I don't know enough about
the KGB I've got to learn more this was
the perfect opportunity and also I've
been obsessed with Oswald for more than
thirty years you know had he done it had
he done it was he part of a conspiracy
so I I said yes without any great
palaver back and forth and in September
you know this would be 92 September 92
moved over to Minsk and Larry and I
worked together with a young lady a
translator named Mila whom he the period
of time married and divorced divorced
after we left Russia who did Larry met
and divorced no he didn't meet her he'd
known her for years how but he married
her while we were still in Russia in
Minsk about PLO rusev and they got
divorced later the point of that is
nothing married and divorced but that
the three of us were there all the time
working in Minsk where there's nothing
to do except eat an indifferent meal and
an unhappy restaurant every night
because Minsk is will never be
famous for its cuisine or at least not
in the next decade or two and and work
and we worked we were constantly
interviewed people we had the great good
fortune that the KGB had shut down all
talk about Oswald after the
assassination because they were
horrified by it
they got paranoid they felt that the
United States had a master plan to start
a war with them and that Oswald was the
what was the point of this war and so
they immediately when it in Mintz they
meet Lee went around to everyone who had
known Oswald and said don't say a word
about him and nobody did
so for thirty years no one had talked
about Oswald you can imagine what a time
capsule we entered when we started
interviewing people who had known him
and we're his friends now where did you
live in Minsk well I lived in a
apartment house that was like every
other apartment house in Minsk there's
no differentiation as such you know in
other words you can be a worker you
could be a doctor you can be a professor
you could be a manicurist everyone lives
at the same level which is a fairly low
level I had a small three room apartment
which was pretty good in a dreary corner
which was like all the other dreary
quarters in in Mintz the difference is
that down in Minsk is is that if you
were an intellectual you live know
better or you a doctor or scientist you
live no better unless you were very very
high and then a worker in fact you may
have even earned less money a month but
what you did have is you had your
superiority which is you had your
essential class superiority which is you
were cultured and they were not and I
found this out because one day I was
living in a workers quarter and the only
way I knew I was living in a workers
quarter was that every Friday and
Saturday night there'd be a bunch of
kids 17 and 18 years old we'll be
getting drunk on the entrance to this
dingy apartment house and when I'd come
back I was always driven up in a little
car with a driver I get out and they'd
offered me homebrew vodka and I happen
to be on the wagon at that time because
I thought if I start drinking in Minsk
I'll never stop so I was on the wagon
for those six months I haven't so I'd go
no no no and I point to my stomach or
make some token and I say yeah American
ski let it all go
and it was you know they were they were
tough but they were
Jovie on the funny way and was I was
just a curiosity you know who's this old
gang he's an American who's little among
us and since I couldn't speak much more
in about 10 or 20 words of Russian I
couldn't learn and I tried it was you
know I if I were taught sort to cry with
frustration I would have cried all the
way I couldn't learn Russian but I
couldn't and so that was all of it and
then one day a woman that we were
interviewing came by in the same car she
was picked up first and the driver
picked me up and we're doing to the
place to the hotel where she be
interviewed and I said to her tell me
about the neighborhood I live in and so
she's a knowin it's a workers quarter
she said I was very shocked when I found
you there now the reason she was shocked
as I was a writer and a Larry Schiller
had done his best to indicate to
everyone there that I was a immensely
esteemed writer that an incredibly
esteemed writer from America and come to
live among them which I say it was a
boon because I certainly couldn't do
that for myself and the woman had heard
that and so here is this oh here's this
esteemed writer living in a low quarter
well I can tell you my apartment house
was just as good as any other apartment
house in town but it was just you didn't
live with workers so you had this
incredible snobbery this incredible
class system but equal equal economic
life
it was very autumns the way people have
to find a social superiority no matter
how and she just couldn't the only
reason was a workers quarter was that
this apartment house was near a factory
with all those people worked so they
would get when they got an apartment
they would get one in this apartment
houses it was near the factory what
months of and what year we actually live
in there was there I was there from
September 92 to february 93 not
constantly I come back to America the
family here I fell so I'd come back
about every three or four weeks I'd come
back for a few days
I lived with jet land it's not eight
hours difference it was quite a jet line
you start out by talking about Marina
Oswald
why did you begin with her well I began
with her a attack
who had an extraordinary experience
during the war and I thought that would
set the stage her aunt valya is a
wonderful woman sort of salt of the
earth and and it goes through these
incredible experiences and had this odd
sweet positive attitude and marina was
more complex than her aunt and more I
wouldn't say the SteriPEN unlike that
where it's unfair it's pejorative but
she had been twisted by life more she
was angrier she was more complicated she
had many more things bothering her and
the book begins with an valya who goes
up has a husband loves and lives in
Minsk and then comes this niece from
Leningrad who's troubled so that's how
the book begins and then at the end of
this first long chapter about 30 pages
that East Marina comes home one night
and turns to the aunt and says valya get
up get the rest
I brought an American home make some
coffee
show some culture and some values gets
up and learns that this nice young
Americans very neat has come and his
name is Lee Harvey Oswald so that's how
the book begins and how did you is the
aunt still alive oh yeah very much and
did all these folks talk to you sit down
and you interviewed him yeah you and
Larry Schiller together oh we always
with the translator which made for I've
told this before it was worth telling
again we had great frustration because
Larry and I having done the execution of
song used to be able to interview
sometimes we lived four or five people
in a day was really really got an awful
lot done let me interrupt
Hevy tell us for those that have not
read it what's the executioner song it's
a book I wrote about Gary Gilmore the
same sort of book very roughly in that
it consisted interviewing a great many
people than writing a book based on the
interviews and Gary Gilmore was he was a
man who killed two people in Utah and
then demanded that he he was given the
death penalty and he demanded that it be
executed and what year was this well you
have me there it was 1977 78 right in
there and your book was a best-seller
back then
yes well okay then now let's go to this
one well don't you two have to call
well
the
problem was that we had we be
interviewing a Russian so we needed one
hour for the English one hour for the
Russian in one hour for arguing with our
translator because she's have a very
definite idea of how you spoke and I
can't learn a lot about Soviet society
which is just ending at that point by
her attitudes for instances we might ask
a question on the order of what year was
it that your father was in the gulag
since this had come up earlier in the
conversation even roundabout way and she
said will not ask that question it will
wreck the interview you will insult him
by such a question they will not be able
to go on so we said well ask the
question why you want to ask it so she'd
asked the question and she get an answer
and then we turn to say what did you ask
them and she'd say I said to them was
there a year which was worse for your
family than other years and through that
you began to get a sense of how
roundabout everything was in the old
Soviet Union that people became not
evasive but they phrased questions in
such a way that there were no sharp
edges there was no handle to the
conversation so that could not be
repeated definitively afterward in such
a way as to incriminate you and it
opened a great deal because you have
that contrast between the essential
brusque approach of Russians you know
it's a I don't know the finesse in
Russian there's a great deal of it
apparently but immediately in a little
bit you can learn there's a bit of a
bust approach you know it's it there no
there no definite articles and
indefinite articles and you wrote that
way a lot in the beginning of this you
get the quality of it yeah
how many people would you say you sat
down and talked to in Minsk well also in
Moscow cooking interviewed a good many
people in Moscow as well altogether I
think we must have interviewed I had I
guess 60 people 50 or 60 and they were
in depth it was different the execution
of song exhaustive interview 300 people
but here first of all the number of
people were limited not everyone had
known Oswald well enough to bear an
interview and the other was it took so
long you really had to work very slowly
and carefully and then we probably
interviewed in depth there's certain
people we saw it
ten interviews and by the way how he got
into Minsk well the way he got some ends
by way of Moscow he arrived in Moscow as
a tourist on a deluxe ticket and in
those days there was always a great
mystery remain about how he got there
but I think that mystery was over
exaggerated because in fact in those
days if you were landed in Finland and
you're willing to buy at the Luke's
ticket to get into Moscow the Russian
embassy in in Finland would send you on
quickly they liked the idea of tourists
coming and giving dollars and moving in
so amantadine in Moscow he announced
only first a second day he was there to
his in torez god whose name was Rima
that he wished to become a Soviet
citizen he want to give up his American
citizenship and we got a Soviet citizen
and she was very taken with this she was
intensely patriotic as most young and
towards girls were in those days and she
loved the audio she said she would help
him but of course they quickly got
nowhere and a half on the fifth day he
when he was told he'd have to go home
and they were nobody was going to take
him because for the Russians this was
extremely odd and unpleasant that you
know the KGB was immediately brought in
a course and they're actors who is this
man why is he coming he's an ex-marine
and he wants to live among us there's
something wrong here now in the
beginning I didn't believe that they'd
be that in different than that cautious
but as I got to know them what you came
to understand is that in Russia the key
thing was not to make a mistake you know
if you're gonna do your job do in such a
way that you make no serious mistakes
and slowly you'll get promoted over the
years
don't do anything bold because it can
get you in terrible trouble we can
boomerang they had the memory of all the
Stalin years after all you just never
want it to be someone who could be
noticed and so the idea that someone's
going to give him permission to stay in
the country or give him citizenship that
had to go up to the very top well it
wasn't time to get up to the very top in
the first five days so they kind of
ignored him and they decided we'll send
him back let him start in America and
get admission here and all that do it
properly from the Russian embassy in
Washington so at that point he made a
suicide attempt now the suicide attempt
we discovered as we interview the
doctors and then was that he was he was
a superficial attempt it was a phony
suicide attempt he slashed one wrist but
he didn't slash it very deeply not
deeply enough to kill himself so they
now they couldn't send him back they're
not gonna send back somebody just try to
commit suicide it would have been a
scandal in the international press since
America already had been full of notices
about how this marina defected so what
were they gonna do they put him in a
hotel in Moscow the Metropole I believe
and they waited and it's decided what to
do with him and months went by and
before long and the first week or two
after they sent him back he went over to
the American Embassy and he turned in
his passport or said he wanted to and he
wanted to take up Russian citizenship
and that made them even more suspicious
because they had bugs planted in all the
walls and everyone's yelling at the
Consul Richard Schneider I want to turn
in my passport I want to become a
Russian citizen and their attitude was
why is he yelling if he knows anything
at all he knows particularly he's a CIA
man he knows that we have bugs on the
wall and so why is he doing all this to
get our attention it makes no sense at
all
a man who seriously wanted to come a
Russian citizen would speak quietly at
this point he wouldn't yell yelling is a
way of indicating he's false so given
all these permutations for the KGB
they just debated and debated what do we
do with them it's possible he's sincere
if he's sincere and no forgive this was
still 1959 early 1960 in those days they
had much more optimism about what's
going to happen to their system they
felt things would improve and they'd end
up with a you know a fine system and
eventually the entire world might be
communist in those days I didn't see
themselves as a as a hopeless dwindling
Empire so they thought it'd be terrible
if they don't accept him if he's sincere
but if he's not sincere what do they do
with him what do they do with him what
are they doing it became an obsessive
question because what sort of CIA man is
that the CIA sent over a man committed
suicide on us
four-fifty in the country this is
ridiculous unless maybe he's a new kind
of CIA animal maybe they sent over an
oddball to see how we'll react and so
they can study our processes well in
that case you know the old saying hit me
said the sadism I won't hit me said the
masochist
I won't such a sadist so what do they do
they decide to observe him all right
well that point we started arguing with
them we started saying well weren't you
interested in his military information
he was a Marine who had all this radar
information weren't you interested in
that and they said no our sources in
Japan where he served were excellent we
knew everything he knew I said no no
that's not good enough you know I know
enough about espionage to know that any
little bit of new information you get
can always be a possibly of great value
why didn't you debrief him it's very
hard to believe you didn't debrief and
they said well it's possible that we law
cuz with the KGB if your question was
good enough they'd give you a fair reply
they said well it's possible we might
have lost a little bit of information
here or there and I might even have been
valuable but we had a way the
possibilities and the probabilities and
from our point of view we didn't want to
take any overt action we were tempted to
but we wouldn't and so we just observed
him the next question is where do we
observe a Moscow so dangerous city but
also so far as there he can get to
trouble we have a scandal he can commit
suicide again this or that let's set him
to Minsk that's a quiet city where the
level of living is pretty good for us
how far from Moscow oh it's about 400
miles 450 miles little south of Moscow
and east near near the Polish border and
we have a very good KGB there because
they're used to doing all sorts of
border investigations with English spies
coming in American spies coming in
people crossing the border in various
ways so they've gotten very good at
detecting foreign spies so we'll send
them there and we'll observe them in
Minsk
and they did for the next two years and
four months they observed them and very
often were bored with him because he led
a very quiet life but
occasionally they had great shocks
because at one point he married a young
girl Marina who was the niece not only a
value but was the niece of a colonel in
the NVD which is to the KGB's roughly as
the FBI as to the CIA how old by the way
was both Lee Oswald and marina at that
time when they got married she was a
year younger than him and at that point
they got married he was 22 I think 21
going on 22 they were married they were
married in April of 61 and at that point
he was his birthday was October so he's
not yet 22 by the way we've got some
fresh tea for you there if you both
thank you for wonderful he he committed
the assassination or they mean they he
allegedly assassinated President Kennedy
when he was 24 years old and and by the
way bit I know we're jumping to the end
of this time goes by so fast on these
things in the what was your conclusion
after all this about did he well the two
hairs of the conclusion originally I was
gonna do a book about Oswald in Minsk in
fact that was the working title
but by the time I finished that that's
half the book I felt that I'd learned a
lot about him I had some sense of what
he was like in a room he was like a
character and a novel to me but I had no
idea at all of whether he was innocent
or guilty the feeling generally was I
remember at my house which published
case closed by Gerald Posner the feeling
was they were all very Pro poser at that
point when they read this and they said
golly it seems like he didn't do it he
seems innocent well because he was very
most of the Russian salman's rather
passive and gentle and particular ones
and Minsk and you know not a fellow to
really do big things after the
assassination very few of the Russians
believed he'd done it maybe a third of
them at most
most of them felt it was an American
plot and that they'd used him because
he'd lived in the Soviet Union so I felt
not satisfied with what I'd learned and
I thought I'll write a hundred page
epilogue about coming back to America
and that hundred page epilogue became a
400-page of second
vol as I got into it because I
discovered the Warren Commission report
had endless uses but they weren't the
ones which for which people have
recently discarded the Warren Commission
report it's really no good at all
considering the effort was put in as an
investigation they cause water
accumulated a huge amount of material
there's very little interpretation very
few leads were followed up it speak of
as you know its value as an
investigative force was equal to a dead
whale decomposing on a beach but they
were wonderful but there was wonderful
material on the Warren Report you notice
we find all kinds of little short
stories and extrordinary little moments
and you get a picture of the time in the
Warren Report that's really historians
and 200 years we'll be going through
that to get an idea what life was like
in America in that period you say they
were 26 by M yeah and when you say
volumes how big of well you're dealing
with you're dealing with very small
print and equipment he lines to a page
maybe 60 70 lines to 60 lives to a page
and 500 page volumes and the first 13 or
14 as I recall our testimonies and then
the remaining volumes are evidence of
various sorts documents how much of that
have you read I probably read it up well
familiar with just about all that but I
probably read more than half of it I had
time to it I had to get the pages
enlarged to read it to type was so small
it's not a comfortable book to read
which was why so few people ever looked
at it he said where is it available oh I
think you can get it from the government
or in a library and in this book
you've got transcripts from that some of
the some of the Warren Report stuff is
in here and then the interviews that
you've talked about you there's some
narrative but there's also some KGB
transcripts yes where does that come
from and what is it about well they
promised us a file and we got a quick
look at the entire oswald file the way
nightline's got a quick look at the file
and then they've pumps in libero it also
lists and we had a team there to work
with it and translate these 600 pages of
the file
but troubles began in Belarus which is
the Stasi in East Germany got into a
great deal of trouble with their sources
who had been exposed and so people that
you thought were your good friend and
have been informing on you for 10 years
15 years there were all hell broke loose
and East Germany over that so in Belarus
people who worked for the KGB began
saying what are you doing giving away
these files you've got to stop that it
will have trouble here so then we got
into a back-and-forth with the KGB where
they'd give us something or wouldn't
give us something we never knew and we'd
work from day to day and spent the spare
time because we accumulated spare time
interviewing other people and a lie
after a while could figure out who a lot
of the sources were and finally what
they did generally is they restricted
Munsell material to stuff that involved
Oswald alone like civilians of Oz wall
or Oswald and marina and we had pretty
thorough files on Oswald marina and
their conversations and home you spent
five days with marina yeah in Texas
where is she now in Texas she lives in
Texas with her former husband with her
former us yes well they have a child
they were married for about ten years
got divorced and then decided they
wanted to live together again but were I
guess for whatever reason decided not
wanting to get married again
what town does she live in oh I don't
know if she wants it revealed it's
within the Dallas area and some 100
miles of Dallas why did she talk to you
Oh
once again the liquidus mr. Schiller he
gets things done I don't know if I had
to go out and get her for an interview I
wouldn't have succeeded he had worked
with her earlier she knew him and I
think she trusted him to a degree she's
a little frustrated though isn't she
when you in the interview frustrating
well we had she one of the things that
was fascinating with marina is I came in
expecting to meet a woman who was fairly
devious and what I discovered is that
she really the truth is terribly
important to her she had that reputation
for years after the assassination that
she was a liar but nobody ever ever
attempted to put it in context there she
was a young woman unhappily married
whose husband's been accused of killing
of a president she's a Russian she lives
this great terror that some wagons gonna
scoop her up
overnight and liquidator is used to be
healed and happened in Russia my god
what would I happen to her these
powerful people from the Secret Service
and the FBI are all talking to her so
she feels now that she was brainwashed
then and she was just eager to serve
them at that point she was terrified and
she was doing her best to tell them what
she felt they wanted to hear so her
story kept changing and changing and
changing in its details and the general
attitude is we're dealing with a total
liar but in fact I thought are very
truthful her memory is almost shattered
by the media bombardments of 30 years
and the shock of living with it and so
forth so her recollection of details is
not that good
how old is she now well she was 30 years
plus at the time we interviewed was 63
so she was I think for about 19 when she
baby from 52 what she looked like well
says she's extraordinary blue eyes
absolutely beautiful
look like diamonds and that was always a
fee she was a very good-looking young
girl quite attractive
now she's 52 years old she's had a tough
life so you might say some of that shows
it's a very small thin argenta over with
guilt I mean she's so fused with big
guilt as Russians Russians are great of
two things compassion and guilt if
you're going to generalize a lot of
people and they live with guilt I mean
that Russian Orthodox Church you ever go
into one you can see the intense guilt
and devotion of people are in it and she
had a very religious grandmother so she
she'd not religious herself and she grew
up in this in the deep grip of
responsibility of spiritual
responsibility very interesting woman
that how's your English it's very fast
very fluent and grammatically nothing
remarkable it's her mind works very
quickly she's quite bright but her her
syntax leaves quite a bit how old are
your children well I don't know she
wouldn't want us to meet her children
but I could reconstruct that the first
child was born in 62 so the oldest child
was 31 at that point 33 today does she
go by the name Oswalt and she take her
no it's her husband's our importer
Marina Oswald Porter at one point and I
don't have it
I'm not turn to the page I think I
remember you Hearst
something effect you wouldn't ask
Jacqueline Kennedy these kind of
questions yes what was that about
oh we were asking her about you see one
of the things that happened here was
that in in Minsk there was a tremendous
amount of gossip about her life in
Leningrad so we were following on on the
trail of it so to speak and to us it was
very important whether she'd had a wild
life in Leningrad that was truly wild
you know because it was very ugly talk
about her life there or whether it'd
been exaggerated and because we felt
that had an enormous effect upon the
marriage since unconsciously Oswell be
reacting for that in the most intense
fashion so we did pursue it on that it
was very painful and difficult and ugly
for her the question but when we when I
finally arrived at is that she'd had a
mildly wild life of Leningrad the way
any average American girl of seventeen
who's very good-looking and doesn't have
a happy home life is gonna have there
was nothing extraordinary about I've
ever said at one point all right I'm
gonna give you the key to my life and
she told us about how she was raped once
when she was seventeen and I looked at
an amazement and I said that's the key
it's it's a wax key because it was a
story that a hundred thousand American
girls could have told you know Isaac
thinks some incredible revelation you
know you know credibly sorted life this
was much smaller but I realized that her
guilt is so enormous because she was
brought up very properly by a
grandmother her guilt was so intense
that she saw little a few things a few
small things she done in Leningrad is
incredibly evil and bad and she felt
she'd gotten married on false pretenses
because you hadn't told Oswald that so
in fact what we were looking for were
the psychological realities of that
marriage which was an unstable unhappy
marriage where there were half in love
with one another and half absolutely at
odds all the time and a lot of these
transcripts that you show from Minsk
have them arguing constantly in their
bedroom and yell it one interesting
thing I remember is that the KGB shut
down at 11 o'clock at night though yeah
the transcription service well good cops
they want to get to sleep they want to
go home see their family
get a little sleep it's a tough job you
got to sit in a small room look through
a peephole the Russians were very proud
that in 1960 they discovered fiber
optics and they used to have a hole
they'd put in the walls about the size
of a pinpoint and if they didn't assert
a fiber optic I suppose that a lens on
the other slide so they could see what
was going on in the other room and I
suppose they heard from various bugs and
they could see what was going on between
those two people in that room yeah and
but you know how long was going if they
were going to sleep why should the
transcriber stay up all night so now we
used to ask them about that we used to
say well you know if thought was that
important why did you quit on eleven
o'clock and the KGB felt that we were
talking to the most honest it was that
we called the developer he was the
analyst in charge of the entire
situation and said well you know and
there were various reasons what was the
budget the budget couldn't pay for
24-hour surveillance
the FBI runs it the same problem all the
time how important is the case how much
he will how many funds you want to
allocate to that because you're not
gonna have it for something else in this
second we didn't get to the conclusion
of the second part of this in the end
again you reach the conclusion after
Minsk about Lee Harvey Oswald what did
you reach at the end the conclusion I
reached is that he probably did it I
thought there was a 75% certainty that
it was a lone gunman but I had janab out
with a great many qualifications because
the first of which was that if I'd been
a lawyer I could have gotten them off or
any good lawyer could have gotten them
off because there was so much confusion
in the evidence and it's so very hard to
be able to state definitively that he
did it there's an awful lot of evidence
that would have him doing it but there's
an awful lot that wouldn't there always
the great questions how did he get from
the sixth floor to the second floor
without breathing heavily in 60 seconds
how could he who was a bad shot I've
shot so successfully and skillfully
they're all these these questions how
could that magic bullet have done what
it did you know and so forth these
questions I don't pretend to answer them
and it's quite possible but but if I've
been a lawyer as I say I could have used
those questions to win over a jury I
felt funny that he did it because it was
the logic of his life
and but you have to read the book to
know what I'm talking about how many
books have you written
I don't know 25 26 27 depends which call
books a couple of them were put together
out of other books so let's call it 25
what was the best seller of all those of
all of them well I don't know maybe the
make of the dead maybe the executioner's
home and where does this book go on your
list as you know experiences in your
life how important is this one this is a
book like harlots ghosts which was long
before this he's more important to me
because it was an imaginative work where
I had to make it all up myself
practically ancient evenings as an
example like that but I really had to
make it up this book I had the help of
putting this way the writing of this was
less exciting less scary than when
you're making it up from day to day
because when you're making love each day
and they say you've got to go in a given
morning and you're going to start
writing about the Battle of Kadesh in
Egypt 1000 BC and you want to write the
greatest battle scene since Tolstoy
you're scared that morning when you walk
in if you're not comfortable at all but
in this a lot of the writing was done in
the interviews you see in the interviews
here it's almost if you're shaping the
book in your mind and as it proceeds it
changes it's analogous to what you feel
when you're talking to me as I talk you
were gonna go in one direction but now
you're gonna go in another because if
something came up that's interesting
and in a certain sense that's the way
this book got written by the time we
done all the interviews you went said
the book was half written for me
Larry Schiller is your partner in this
but there's a Howard Schiller that did
design the son took the jacket nice
jacket and what's who's what's house is
this that house of the house that Oswald
lived in on Neely Street in Dallas in
nineteen in early 63 months before to
810 months before of the assassination
of President Kennedy and it was in that
house that he set out to kill and my
belief of general Walker and took the
shot at general Walker who is general
Walker general Walker was a extreme
right-wing or virtually a fascist who
was one of the heads of the John Birch
Society
and Oswald believed that he was gonna be
a future Hitler and he thought it would
be a virtuous act to shoot him when had
you gathered all the information you
needed to begin writing it doesn't work
that way what happens as I get into a
book before I've accumulated all the I
had all the information about Russia
that I needed ninety-five percent of it
when I came home and started writing
Oswald in Minsk but by the time I
finished that as I say I thought I was
gonna add a hundred pages about Oswald
in America that hundred pages became
four or five hundred pages because I
began to a new research and as I did I'd
stopped writing for long periods and do
the new research and so the second half
of the book took as long as the first
half easily and and then you finish it
and then you go over it and then you
start to shape it more and more and more
once you know what you'll have you shape
it more so the writing of this book is
what I'd say was easier than the writing
of other books I've done on the other
hand was I got more out of it I'm fond
of the book because I have this
extraordinary spirits of living in Minsk
you know I just felt well hell I'm in my
late 60s my turn I had my 70th birthday
in Moscow a couple years ago and I just
felt I'm not dead yet you know you know
this is not so bad I can live in a
strange place and get a lot out of it
and I'm working hard and all that was
fun where do you write I've got a little
studio and Brooklyn a couple blocks in
my house no telephone nothing there so I
go there and when I go there the only
thing I ever do there is work so it's
wonderful I'm like a dog with a
conditioned reflex no television no
television no telephone nothing no right
not even not even my wife wants me to
get a portable telephone I refused
because well she says what if you get
sick over there nobody because you have
no telephone because what's the reason
for that I don't be tempted there's an
old Jewish belief that you build a fence
around an impulse and that's not good
enough you build a fence around the
fence so no telephone and and what do
you write with or how do you write I
write longhand with a pencil and I've
got a marvelous assistant named Judith
McNally and she will type it up the next
day and then I go over it and since at
my age you begin to forget things very
easily
marvelous because I hardly remember what
I wrote the day before
now it's typed and says if someone else
wrote it and I'll go through it and I'll
say who was the idiot who wrote that
stupid sentence and I'll fix enough and
I'll edit it and as I edit it I said
I'll give it back to her and she sends
it back each day so it's as if I have my
own word I don't work with a word
processor but I do have the benefits of
one how long have you worked in this
office in Brooklyn oh I have to think
now this particular place I've worked in
for about 10 years now maybe 12 I used
to work at home I used to have a little
eerie off the top of my apartment
suppose we've got an odd apartment and
there was a little cubby hole up on the
top with a wonderful view of the harbour
so I used to work up there what time of
day do you write Oh generally I'll start
late in the morning and if we're not
going out that evening I won't finish
till 9 o'clock at night so it plays hell
with our social life do you have any
brightest block ever no but I think I
may have had a certain sense of how to
avoid it
I'm keeping my fingers crossed it's a
it's a foolish author who Bradley never
had writer's block how do you avoid it
well let me amend what I'm saying when I
was younger I had years when I used to
wonder whether I'd ever write another
book and I didn't wouldn't write for six
months at a time but since I wasn't on
anything I didn't see him as writer's
block or I had a couple books I started
and you know how to go on with that I
dropped by never I never called it
writer's block because it didn't feel
that way and I think what happens is
there's something deep in the
unconscious that says to you you can go
ahead with this this book can be written
there certain books you can try it if
you're writing about them terribly
charged emotional material and you're
not ready to live with it then I think I
think you're not writing anymore you're
engaged in a transaction with yourself
that probably is analogous to a patient
with a psychoanalyst you know where
psychoanalyst are always talking about
how they can't get patients to deliver
certain sorts of obvious material
because they won't face it so I think a
writer's block probably is rate of that
but you know all writers have certain
strengths and weaknesses and I think one
of my strengths has been that I've been
able to avoid writer's block and it
isn't it isn't a preoccupation of mine
what I'm concerned with is how good is
it going to be
where did you grow up in Brooklyn I was
born in New Jersey but I grew up in
Brooklyn then I went to Harvard to talk
about talk about questions of identity
I'll even know I didn't even know that
problem existed that you had a search
for your own identity but going from
Brooklyn or Harvard in those years back
in the late 30s early 40s was quite a
change did when did you first get
interested in politics Oh probably in
1948 after the lake and the dead came
out because I was 4 Henry Wallace
and so I used to speak for him a little
bit what did that mean I was 4 Henry
Wallace well he had the Progressive
Party I guess yeah we have to talk to
people who were born long after that in
1948 Henry Wallace ran for president it
was a left-wing candidate very very
roughly analogous to say if Jesse
Jackson would run as a third party
candidate the it was called the
Progressive Party in those days was
about far to the left as Jesse Jackson
would be Wallace was of course white
would've been a former Secretary of
Agriculture couldn't be more different
from Jesse Jackson in any way I mean too
many poles apart the only parallel would
be that political positions would be
about the same in terms of geography
topography but that got me interested
and then I've always been it was more or
less one way or another for all these
years where are you on the political
spectrum today I am what I call left
conservative and what I I can find it in
a variety of ways but maybe if we talk
about politics if we're going to it'll
come out if do you have anybody and in
politics today that you admire anybody
any human being that's running for an
office or wants to run no no no a moment
I wish Mario Cuomo would would run I'd
be excited by that which he'd run for
president at least in the New Hampshire
primary because I think of nothing else
I'm a Democrat but but I think I think
Bill Clinton needs a shocker to he's
he's whipped wobbling in the center he's
in fact I have a I see him really if I
got a word for him now
you know gore Vidal used to call
Eisenhower the golfer
so I would call Bill Clinton vidoe fan
we need a nice seventeen-year-old
peasant girl named Joan of Arc to come
to and say President Clinton you will
save the nation he's not going to save
it by doing what he's doing now
you said something real early in this
talk chat about Norman Podhoretz they
used to be we should be great friends
and he's just retired as editor of
commentary magazine what's that the
magazine the American Jewish Committee
or why did you used to be friends and
he's in the office variety reasons one
of the most basic reasons of friendship
we got along we enjoyed each other's
company
there's so forth and so on and
politically we were fairly close in
those days and then he moved way over to
the right which wouldn't have bothered
me in a funny way I've always felt it's
it's obscene if politics gets in the way
of friendship friendship should be more
important than politics but in fact I'll
lay the blame on Norman he really didn't
want to have anything to do with me my
vanity tells me as he didn't we'll have
to argue with me that night after night
after night or his newfound security on
the right weapon weekend just a touch
but that's my vanity at any event he
pulled himself away from me today what
what sparked you to talk politics what
issue almost anything I really I mean
one pleasure about being on this program
is there's no commercial I got to tell
you because I think really that when you
start to talk about the violence of
television the violence of television
breeds not only is that much to do with
the scenarios I think what it has to do
with much much more is if you have young
violent kids and they're watching
something they get interested in it
which is very hard for violent people to
get interested in something outside
themselves because most violent people
are obsessed all the time with
themselves and their inner state the
finally the episode let's say the little
story they're watching on TV and then
BOOM comes the commercial and now
they're violent
they've been interrupted don't interrupt
a violent man you know so this goes long
and then you take five-year-olds who
just have sweet sense8 little brains and
they're being interrupted all the time
they lose a sense of concentration and
and this is that gets me furious you
know my kids my four kids I grew up with
me and they see me screaming at the
television 7:00
commercial comes on but how many kids
about nine they're not all there at the
state all from the same wife no no no I
doesn't married a few times how many
times you in right six times would you
do that over again oh maybe I can't
answer that question without getting an
endless trouble all over the place how
old are they I think funny if you get
married seriously and there's no that's
your life you know there's certain
people who lived in six countries over
their lifetime that's their life they
can save my eight years in Turkey with
fascinating
I love the 15 years I had in Paris I
think a marriage is life that's a
culture and I'd hate to say after 15
years living in Paris I hate France and
everything about it you know in other
words I think when you've had a marriage
since you were living in a culture
because there's no such thing as a woman
who was not a deep culture if anyone out
there is married to a woman who's not a
deep culture may be in the wrong
marriage how would you rate your life
how would I write my life now rate your
life you've done what you wanted to do
but sit down in and out lucky unlucky
but finally I can't I can't complain you
know I think I think if if you can get
to the point where you're not so fused
with self-pity then you've probably done
51 things right every 49 things you did
wrong
I think self-pity is the ultimate
spiritual disease because it's it's it's
anger against God if you will and that
means there's no respect for God no
there's no respect for God we're in a
lot of trouble now you see why I call us
of a left conservative on the one hand I
think everybody ought to have a bed at
night and enough to eat enough medical
care I think it's obscene if you have
the very wealthy people and very poor
people there's got to be a safety net a
true safety net the rich people would
sleep a lot better if everybody was poor
was taken care of and if they don't work
that's their sin that's their hard life
you can't sit in judgment on them I
remember when I ran for mayor and 69 and
one point some people said to Breslin
myself who Jaden
Breslin myself Jimmy Breslin I ran
I was running for mayor he's running for
president City Council in New York and a
primary and our campaign was halfway
interesting we were one of five sets of
candidates and somebody said you know if
you could improve your welfare program
you'd if you could come up with
interesting welfare program you might
get somewhere really people start taking
more seriously so we decided we go out
and pay some visits some black people up
in Harlem and talk about welfare and our
people found somebody to talk to a
couple of women who headed up a very
important black welfare program there
and we went up way up to Harlem and went
to visit them there were two big strong
black women sitting at a desk and in a
shabby little room and we thought we'd
say now see here madam we can help each
other let us discuss this and extend
what happens one of them started talking
she said mrs. rich bucks over on Fifth
Avenue she says I got a Cadillac and I'm
getting welfare and I'm riding around
the Cadillac and how dare I
and I say and I cannot use the next word
she used on television she said banker
my Cadillac is eight years old and it's
in the garage all the time and she
drives around a Rolls Royce with a
chauffeur and then another woman the
other woman said and mrs. so-and-so over
on Park Avenue she says I got seven
eight illegitimate children and I'm
getting money for all them and I say
blank her I had those children she had
her seven abortions and they one of them
looked at us and said we want our share
of the waste and I thought well it has
to be said that there's something from
their argument we nod it and said thank
you thank you ladies and we left we had
no welfare program the the point behind
it I think is that so long as there's a
sense a huge waste at the top there's no
way the people at the bottom are going
to say thank you thank you for taking
care of us and finally the the real
tragedy is not that people at the top
are inferior the people at the bottom
are not putting their shoulder to the
wheel the real tragedy is when people at
the bottom can't work and don't work
they're in misery their in spiritual
misery
and it affects their children that goes
on generation after generation as it has
in England and being on the dole is no
fun so in that sense I'm left I think
I'm a left winger I think I think we've
got to have a safety net that's profound
and let's stop worrying about the rich
surviving rich always take care of
themselves or almost out of time on
Oswald's tale after someone finishes
this book off what what do you want to
conclude what's what's the I want to
think about the Cold War and what a
tragic comedy it was that's personified
by the life of this one man who really
attempted to deal with the Cold War he
went over to the Soviet Union because he
was in thumb test of what was going on
in America he got to satisfy the Soviet
Union came back to America now he was
dissatisfied with both countries but he
lived at the bottom but he really saw
the ironies of both countries in the way
there was that that there was just no
need for that Cold War their vote for
horrible systems as far as he was
concerned so I want them just to ponder
that that that and ideally if they found
it was thing enough what do I also want
I liked those who've never read another
book of mine or read another book is
there a next book there better be a next
book fiction nonfiction I think I'm
gonna try to do the second volume of
harlots ghosts Norman Mailer author of
Oswald's tale an American mystery thank
you very much for joining us thank you